thierry amouroux infirmiers porte parole
du syndicat national des professionnels
infirmiers
bonsoir série amouroux merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rtl france donc
demain c'est le grand jour un grande
mobilisation nationale avec évidemment
les gestes barrières selon vous est ce
que c'est un appel qui va être suivi
alors oui il ya un millier de
rassemblement qui sont organisées dans
toute la france autour des hôpitaux ou
des états pad dans les différentes
villes et l'idée c'est justement que
l'ensemble de la population soit au tour
d'aidés soignants pour défendre leur
hôpital et protéger leur vie avec un
service de santé à leur service et est
donc ainsi les la population va faire
pression sur les maires qui président de
l'instance de l'hôpital et sur les
parlementaires dans leur circonscription
parce que ce sont les parlementaires
qu'ils votent le budget de l'hôpital
chaque année et chaque ennemi une vote
un budget en baisse depuis dix ans
c'était important pour vous de
manifester en marge du ségur de la santé
parce que j'ai vécu à l'heure quand on
connaît pas bien le le dossier on se dit
voilà il ya des négociations quand même
qu'ils sont en cours très activement
pour les soignants et pourtant la
pression est maintenant plus que jamais
oui parce que clairement eu le ségur de
la santé ne se passe pas grand chose
c'est une suite de monologues il y a pas
de concertation et encore moins de
négociations vous parliez des salaires
mais rien n'est prévu en termes concrets
ni la somme finale ni
combien de temps il va falloir d'année
pour atteindre cette somme finale à rien
n'est prévu du tout sur les ouvertures
de lits et les créations de postes
rien n'est prévu non plus donc c'est
pour ça qu'on fait vraiment appel à la
population pour mettre la pression
si vous voulez c'est un bras de fer
entre les premiers de cordée et les
premiers de corvée parce que on a
vraiment l'impression d'être corvéables
à merci et que au moment de prendre
vraiment le problème à bras le corps il
n'ya pas visiblement les moyens de le
faire vous voyez il ya des milliards qui
ont été débloqués pour l'aéronautique
pour l'automobile et pour l'hôpital
oui mais attendez on va réfléchir on va
se donner deux mois pour essayer de
trouver une solution
il ya eu 50 rapports qui ont été faits
sur les dix dernières années pour
améliorer la situation de l'hôpital
elle n'a fait que se dégrader encore
aujourd'hui il ya des problèmes de
fermeture de lits à tour à saint-etienne
au vinatier près près de lyon à besançon
voilà les au quotidien nous hospitalier
nous sommes obligés de nous battre pour
conserver un nombre de lits suffisant
donc voilà un peu le bras de fer dans
lequel on n'a plus trop naïve mais est
ce que le gouvernement a le choix
cette crise a révélé au monde entier les
lacunes de l'hôpital public a eu ce
soutien massif de la population
l'hommage du 14 juillet en france et
qu'on est dans les symboles mais mais
tout de même ils vont être obligés de
faire des gestes nous n'êtes même pas un
peu confiants mais écoutez nous avons le
recul du plan hôpital de novembre
dernier annoncée par le premier ministre
qui nous disaient qu'ils allaient
consacrer des milliards l'hôpital et un
mois après ils ont bu voter le
le budget de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour l'année 2020 et l'argent
n'y était pas en fait
le vote de l'ondam se traduisait par une
baisse de 500 millions d'euros sur le
budget de l'hôpital pour 2020 alors
depuis les locaux vides donc on a engagé
davantage de dépenses mais ça n'empêche
qu'on est inquiet si autant de
directeurs d'hôpitaux qui sur le terrain
se permettent de fermer des lits
supprimer des postes
c'est qu'il ya des consignes orales
alors question avec cette manifestation
est ce que finalement elle est autorisée
parce que c'était assez floue aux
événements mais croit parler des
rassemblements hier qui ne semble pas
les bienvenus enfin en pleine épidémie
mais à la fin de cette épidémie en tout
cas ce que tout simplement votre
rassemblement en manifestation est elle
autorisée par les autorités
et vous avez une réponse claire du
conseil d'état qui a rappelé au
gouvernement que le droit en france
s'applique et la règle constitutionnelle
du droit de manifester s'applique voilà
donc ya le rassemblement de paris qui
ira du ministère à l'assemblée nationale
nous avons demandé à être reçu mais le
plus important c'est vraiment où ses
rassemblements dans autour d'un millier
d'hôpitaux une belle mobilisation
populaire de la france qu'on aime
merci en tout cas thierry amouroux et
nous suivons évidemment sur rt france
cette mobilisation demain du personnel
soignant merci à vous